[Music]
65 years ago
about 65 years ago
i came across the ocean from england
to the united states the family settling
in philadelphia
i there attended the public schools
and the boys central high school
eventually but there was an interval
between my attendance
of one of the schools it was not a
direct succession
i was forced out of school
at 11
to stay out two years because the
entrant age of the boysville high school
was 13.
and i was only 11.
so the problem was what to do with me
during the two
extra years
well some of them said some of the
advisors said keep him away from books
and let him develop
physically i said if you do that you
might as well kill me now because i've
got to have my books
so they
modified the decision into saying well
you can have them all right so i got
hold of a book which was called a
magician's own book
a book telling of puzzles and tricks and
all kinds of little things chemistry
experiments electrical experiments
the electrical chapter was what struck
me at once
and they told how to make an electrical
machine out of a wine bottle
and i immediately set to work and
made just such a machine and started it
in operation
and i
got my first view of electric sparks
from that machine my first knowledge of
electricity from that machine
and i made a whole lot of apparatus
which is recommended to be made like
lightened jars
and uh little things of attraction and
repulsion
dancing figures and so on and i had that
whole equipment
along with a stool which was made by
bottles and the and the board for making
the english tool in order to
insulate a person that wanted to be
charged
and recharge them
with a with a uh
arrangement of this kind my father
rather fulfilled the magnitude of my
efforts and
i thought i was got i had to get even
with him somehow so i made a battery of
five jars and put them into operation
and asked him to take the shock
i never heard after he took that shot
anymore interrogation
derogatory remarks about my apparatus
[Music]